there's some significant chatter that
Condoleezza Rice would be an excellent
nominee for the Republican Party and I
have encountered some willingness among
significant figures in the conservative
movement to accept her moderation on
certain social issues because of her
both strings on national security and
because symbolically she would also
illustrate change for the Republican
Party but there are others and there are
many others and if it's john mccain he
needs to win the conservative base and
if he doesn't if he doesn't warm with
the conservative base and then he'll
have to pick a strict conservative for
that position and there is there's a
huge list of these of these men and
women but it's you might see mccain go
for someone who has impeachable
unimpeachable conservative credentials
simply because you want to share up your
flank before you go to war and that's
true in politics as well I really want
to emphasize I'm I could miss several
and that this is purely from a head but
of course candidates like Wesley Clark
the you know the general the former
general from Arkansas helps would help a
good deal I think he learned lessons in
campaigning in 2004 and he certainly
would compensate for Hillary Rodham
Clinton's national security weaknesses
and Barak's know that Hillary and him
both come from this the same state might
pose a small dilemma though he is
southern and Democrats should remember
that they have not won a presidential
race since nineteen sixty with out a
southern ER at the top or the second
slot of the ticket so that's an
important fact to consider too there are
Ken it's like Brian's right to the
governor of Montana i'm not sure if
you'd want it there's the governor of
ohio he says to me he doesn't want it
Strickland he says he told me personally
twice that he's not interested that he's
he's older and that he's happy in Ohio
but he certainly compensates for moral
values weakness
that have haunted the Democratic Party
for a long time and when I see more
values i mean the inference that it has
the conservatives and moderates out
there and there's certainly Jim Webb out
of Virginia that I think is a strong
candidate for the vice presidential slot
and there are many others that I could
name those are just three with no
particular preference though who
certainly help compensate for Democratic
historical weaknesses I would also add
Mark Warner to that mix also from a
junior former governor who's shown a
consistent ability to really close gaps
on such issues is gone sort of haunted
the Democratic Party for some decades